we know that some of her players are
always looking for more challenge
playing in the most unforgiving
conditions and in the highest difficulty
settings for these players our next
hello update will really put their
skills to the test
we are proud to introduce the brand new
tier 1 mote of Ghost Recon wildlands the
idea behind the tier system is to allow
our strongest players to go beyond what
the game currently offers in terms of
challenge when you reach level 30 which
is the max level in the game you have
the opportunity to activate tier what if
you choose to do so the experience with
burning game by completing missions and
challenges allows you to move up in rank
every time you move up a tier the game
becomes more difficult enemies become
more alert part of the takedown and
deadlier than ever
start at tier 15 and move up tiers as
you progress but you can always choose a
state to tier you think provides the
right challenge for you you will also be
able to upgrade your weapons as you move
up the ranks using resources you can
fine-tune your favorite weapons to match
the opposition you face this can be
gathered in game but also through the
free Ghost Recon HQ companion app in a
dedicated guerilla mode we love to watch
our players challenge themselves and
with the new tier 1 mode we cannot wait
to see who will be brave enough to reach
the heights of tier 5 and above
you